Thank you to dollar shave club for sponsoring this video,
go to dollar shave club.com forward slash biographics to get your
star to Sanford, just $5 off to that product, that regular prices
It's one of the worst diseases in history.
Smallpox spent millennia as the scourge of mankind, inflicting death,
wherever it reared its ugly head in the 20th century alone,
it killed some 300 million people, almost as many as the Spanish flu,
but while survivors of the flu returned to normal survivors of smallpox will
after damaged for life, blindness,
infertility and hideous disfigurements were frequent outcomes.
Ones that affected people from all segments of society, princes pharaohs,
emperors, Queens, artists, warriors workers,
all found themselves struck down by the disease that Feld empires
and denials hated cities until one day it stopped in the mid
20th century,
a pushed by the world health organization saw smallpox become the first disease
to ever be completely eradicated.
The last natural case was recorded in 1977.
After thousands of years of suffering, humanity was finally free,
but what was this virus? We drove to extinction. Where did it come from?
And how did it affect the story of humanity? Well,
today we're diving into the life of one of history's great plagues and how
it created our modern world.
[Inaudible].
Of all the nasty viruses that have afflicted mankind.
Few have been as nasty as smallpox once inhaled into your system,
it stays hidden for around 12 days,
almost like an army Lang the perfect ambush in that time,
your life carries on as normal. You go to work, hanging out with friends,
never knowing that your death warrant has already been signed. Then on day 13,
it happens. The first symptoms are headaches, back pain, chills, vomiting.
At first you pray that you're mistaken, that it's just a bad dose of the flu,
but as the 17th day approaches,
you discovered the truth will start to appear inside your throat.
Then spread out like an army marching across your skin. Every inch of you,
this army touches breaks out and hard.
Pus filled lumps with an indentation in the middle after that.
So you're on a roller coaster of pain,
depending on which version of the virus you've caught very early,
a minor or very early major. Your chances of death could be any way from a myth.
3% to a staggering 30 surviving might be even
worse. Once smallpox has finished ravaging your system,
the pastels on your face,
feet and hands scab over and fall off leaving behind hideous pitted scars that
will stay with you for the rest of your life. Even once you recover,
you may be left blinds and in fertile sounds pretty awful, right?
Almost as if a writer with a particularly twisted imagination sat down and tried
to dream up the nastiest science fiction disease they could think of,
but smallpox isn't science fiction.
It existed during the lifetime of anyone older than their mid forties.
And prior to that, it had been around for centuries.
The exact origins of smallpox are still a mystery.
Some have suggested it may date back to his followers, 10,000 BC.
When the neolithic revolution brought us into sustained contact with livestock.
On the other hand, his research in 2016 concluded this.
It may have appeared as late as the 16th century a D for this video though,
we're just going to go with the majority opinion, which says,
all we know is that smallpox had first appeared by 1570 BC.
That's because 15 to 70 BC is the stop date of Egypt's new kingdom and a handful
of mummies from the era. Still show telltale signs of infection.
This includes Ramesses the fifth who had a swath of long dead pastorals dried
out on his cheeks,
likely the first known instances of smallpox killing a leader,
not the most victims were anybody you'd have heard about,
although smallpox afflicted adults,
the majority of those that killed with children and the majority of those were
kids who lived in cramped quarters, where the virus could spread and spread.
It did,
although smallpox was relatively non-contagious compared to stuff like measles.
Once it got hold, it really got hold.
There's a 14th century hits on into tablet describing what may be the disease
sweeping that lands the pandemic raged for 20 years and carried off two rulers
before finally fading. But if that sounds bad,
just know that is far worse to come across the history of Eurasia,
there would be barely a single empire that didn't come into contact with
smallpox at some point or another. In some cases,
this brief brush would be enough to bring their civilization crashing down.
[Inaudible].
If you ever find yourself in the possession of a time machine,
be sure to follow the following advice,
whatever you do do not set the controls for 430 BC Athens last
because Athens in four 30 BC was in the grip of a pandemic that would make
COVID 19 look like an outbreak of rainbows and puppies.
During the second year of the Peloponnesian war,
a disease arrived in the port of Piraeus known as the plague of Athens.
It killed around a third of the population in horrifying fashion.
The historian lucidity, who himself contracted the virus, described it,
thus violent heaps in the head, redness and inflammation of the eyes,
throat and tongue quickly.
Suffused with blood breath became unnatural and fetish,
sneezing and hoarseness violent cough, vomiting, retching, violent convulsions,
the body externally,
not so hot to the touch nor yet to pale and livid color inkling to read breaking
out in pastels and offices, pastels and offices probably sounding familiar.
We don't actually know what caused the plague of Athens,
but smallpox is a major contender. Other possible diseases include measles.
And the bubonic plague smallpox becomes an even more likely contender.
When you hear that some survivors were left blind, whatever it was,
the plague left Athens badly weakened.
They carried off the great lead apparently and contributed to Athens ultimately
losing the Peloponnesian war.
But while the jury is out on whether smallpox was the culprit,
the same copy said of one of the ancient worlds, other great plagues,
the ends of nine plague landed nearly at six centuries.
After the plague of Athens arriving in ancient Rome, around 165,
a D in all likelihood, it was brought from China. Traveling along the silk road,
carried into Europe by the very traders,
trying to escape it where the plague of Athens would kill tens of thousands.
Though,
the answer nine plague would kill millions two weeks off to contact with an
infected person. The victims would come down with fevers, diarrhea, vomiting,
and coughing shortly after that, their skin erupted in Hills,
which would soon form scabs that covered nearly the entire skin.
And if you think that sounds gross, wait till he heard this,
the worst effected would even cough up scabs that had been formed inside their
bodies. Not nice at the plagues height.
Over 2000 people were dying each day in the eternal city,
a number that eventually included emperor Marcus Aurelius.
The final death toll was a staggering 3.5 to 7 million.
It may have contributed to the militaries inability to defend rooms,
German border. Naturally people had all sorts of wacky theories about it scores.
Some said a Roman general open day forbid and door while sacking.
Solutia releasing the plague.
Others that a soldier opened a casket and Babylon's tumble and the God sent him
the plague as a punishment.
It's only with hindsight that we can call the ans unknown plague.
What it most likely was smallpox while smallpox devastated Eurasia as early.
And it also gave them a strange kind of gift with each new pandemic,
Eurasian resistance to the parks grew while it might not sound so great.
It would soon become a very valuable asset.
Some 1,400 years after the end of nine plague,
a group of Europeans would arrive on a continent that had never seen smallpox
before.
It would be thanks to this tiny virus that they soon became the continence mask.
[Inaudible].
The next few centuries.
We're an era of migration for smallpox at some points before the sixth century,
the virus got its tendrils into India and China where cults devoted to smallpox
data is sprang up by the sixth century.
It had reached Japan alongside the weird cross-cultural belief that it could be
stopped by the color red come. The 11th century,
the crusade spread the disease far and wide afflicting corners of Europe that
had never been hit before.
Not long after Portuguese colonists were introducing it to parts of Africa,
making small box a truly global scourge, but the biggest,
most dramatic migration came in the early 16th century a decade or so after
Columbus discovered it smallpox finally set foot in the new Wells. By now,
it was more in Europe than even the black death yet it was destined to give the
Europeans a bit of a helping hands in 15, 20,
or ship carrying someone infected with smallpox often said to be a slave landed
on the shores of Mexico.
This was the of honing Cortez's expedition into Misa America's Heartland
into the Aztec and Bob,
as the Europeans marched on the POCs trailed in their wake.
It wasn't long before it was wreaking havoc. Smallpox was unlike anything.
The indigenous people's immune systems had ever encountered before it's
overwhelmed them. It devastated them. If smallpox was a nightmare for Europe,
then for Misa America, it was nothing short of the apocalypse that October 15,
20 smallpox ravage,
the great Aztec capital of tenor Shipman up to 40% of the population died
as the NSX recorded. As the plague lasted for 70 days,
striking everywhere in the city and killing a vast number of our people.
Souls erupted on our faces. Our breasts saw bellies.
We were covered with agonizing souls from head to foot.
The Europeans were more detached as the Indians did not know the remedy of the
disease wrote one of quarters as team. They died in heaps like bedbugs.
However, you look at it.
Smallpox was devastating for the Aztecs when Cortez conquered Teno Chitlin in
1521,
it was in large part because European germs had already killed so many of its
citizens,
nor would the Aztec EMBA be the only one torn down by the virus in the Andes.
Smallpox arrived ahead of the Europeans in 1528,
the incunabula Wayne and Kropach was carried off by us.
His death sparked a civil war between his two,
as that helped spread smallpox across the Inca lands.
In some places it killed 65 to 90% of the population.
By the time Francisco Pizarro arrived in 1532,
the empire was barely clinging on bizarro, just delivered the killing blow,
but it wasn't just in South America that smallpox made its presence felt not
just below the border where it changed history up in the North.
The colonists would even find a despicable use for it.
But just before we get into what I'm in there,
I do want to take a moment to tell you about today's sponsor dollar shave club.
Now dollar shave club covers all of your grooming needs, shower,
oral care deodorants. Then of course, and most of them importantly shaving.
Now I don't shave my bed. Yeah. I can see that. Yeah,
but I do shave my head and that experience has become a lot better since I
switched to dollar shave club and they're high quality blades and also the high
quality handled, like feeling this thing right now, this is fairly hefty.
I mean, it's got a great way to it.
Dollar shave club sent me the ultimate shave starters that let me run you
through what I got. First of all, of course, there's the prep scrub.
You slap that on your face and you scrub your face down. Well,
I've slap it on my heads and I scrubbed my head down. Uh,
and then you put on the shave butter, that's part two,
there's three parts you put on this shape, butter.
Then use this executive six blade version of bear a the
starter stack, which is what I'd recommend you get.
And then afterwards you pop on post shaved you,
and I've said it before in these ads.
This is my favorite thing because my head it's a little bit dry after a shave.
And I know when I used to shave my face as well,
also used to get a little bit dry there. So this place has shaved you.
This is where it's at, slap that on and you're all good.
So what do you need to visit dollar shave club.com forward slash biographics get
the ultimate shave starter set, but just $5 also.
Why not round out your grooming routine by adding some of the other high quality
products after that,
the restock box ships full size products at their regular price. And, uh,
let's get back to the video shop. Wait,
because it's about to get fairly horrific. If it hasn't been horrific enough.
[Inaudible].
Contrary to what you may have heard.
Smallpox wasn't deliberately introduced into the native American population by
colonists. In fact,
it had already swept the America's like wildfire passing from indigenous group
to indigenous group,
like a really crappy game of pass the parcel where every single prize is over
half your population dying horribly the year before the Mayflower arrived an
epidemic. And what is now new England killed up to 90% of the locals yet.
Even if the colonists weren't standing outside their cabins,
cheerfully handing out infected blankets, they were still on the boxes side.
When an outbreak hit Massachusetts in 1633,
plenty of Puritans believed the grim native death toll was a gift from.
God.
A moment and discuss those blankets.
There's a good chance you picked on this video.
I expect it to hit tales of Calvinists, deliberately giving smallpox to natives.
It's one of the iconic images in the giant picture book titled how the native
Americans got screwed over despite its vast reputation though,
this scene only played out a single time. The year was 1763,
the last year of the French and Indian war that spring Shawnee and Mingo
warriors lead siege to Fort Pitt in what is now Pittsburgh smallpox was already
inside the Fort and the commander wrote to his superiors worrying that it would
spread. So his superior wrote back saying,
why let all that good smallpox go to waste across two letters.
So Jeffrey Amhurst commander in chief of the British forces in North America
wrote,
could it not be contrived to send the smallpox among those disaffected tribes of
Indians? We must on this occasion,
use every stratagem in our power to reduce them,
try every other method that can serve to extubate this ex scrubble sick race.
Interestingly, we don't know if Amherst's instructions were actually followed.
What we do know is that a militia captain not before two,
one William Trent had already tried giving diplomats from the attacking tribes,
a couple of blankets infected with the parks. And that was it.
The one documented time that colonists tried to deliberately give native
American smallpox to be brutally honest though,
while a obviously despicable thing to do it probably didn't make a difference.
Smallpox was already in the native American population.
There were already major outbreaks happening around Fort Pierce.
The moment European germs touched America's shores and natives were already
doomed, but while it had been Europeans, you spread smallpox to the new world.
It would also be a European who finally stopped it in its tracks because it's
time to meet Edward Jenner.
Right?
By the time the 18th century rolls around smallpox had become just a gross fact
of life in Europe alone and killed 400,000 people a year,
including some of the very top of society. Peter, the second of Russia, Mary,
the second thing Linds Louis, the 15th of France,
rural carried away by the disease. It had also acquired its name smallpox,
which was meant to differentiate it from the great parks or what would now call
syphilis yet. Even as Europe suffered,
other continents were already bringing smallpox under control variolation is
thought to a started in 10th century,
China and India before spreading West into the ultimate empire.
The process was as low-tech as it was barf inducing,
basically you'd take the positive. Someone infected with smallpox.
Then make a load of cups in the arm of a healthy person.
And inside the pasta inside them, a couple of weeks later,
a healthy person would come down with a mild case of smallpox recover and to
have a lifelong immunity.
Broadly speaking this wax while the normal risk of death from small box was
around 30% only around 0.5% died from variolation.
But this method wasn't perfect. Although very elated people rarely died.
They were infectious.
This could easily pass on the much more serious case to those who were around
them.
It also required you to have a constant supply of patients with smallpox whose
pass you could take and insert into healthy people.
So it was great as variolation was compared to, you know, dying of smallpox,
it could still be improved.
Luckily someone was about to do.
Just that.
Edward Jenner was a surgeon living in Gloucestershire bucolic slice of England's
famed for its dairy industry.
It was also famed for its cowpox virus that tended to affect the hands of
milkmaids leaving their fingers covered in unsightly pastels.
But here's the thing,
none of those cowpox infected milkmaids ever seemed to catch smallpox.
The popular version of this story is that Jenna was the first person to notice
this, but that's not actually true.
Pretty much all the locals were aware that cowpox meant no smallpox,
a farmer who had Benjamin Jesse had even used cowpox material to deliberately
inoculate his sons against ballparks in 1774.
But then he forgot to tell anyone about this world changing breakthrough.
So it was left to Jenna to discover it independently. In 1796,
Jenna asked a family. He knew if he could borrow that eight-year-old son,
James Phipps,
he then took some cowpox POS from a milkmaid named Sarah Nelms and inserted it
into Phipps's skin.
After Phipps had recovered from a mild case of cowpox Jenna then exposed the boy
to smallpox repeatedly, but fortunately nothing happened to him,
James Phipps. He was immune to the virus today.
Hearing that story mostly makes us think of.
Holy crap. That dude tried to literally give a child smallpox.
What the hell? Okay.
Times, but make no mistake. This was a breakthrough,
the variolation to shame Jenna named his new technique,
vaccination off to the Latin for cow belly hoodie coins. The term.
Then the first anti-vaxxers came crawling out of the woodwork.
There all society told Jenna he shouldn't promulgate some shady wild idea.
If he valued his reputation. Yes,
promulgates Jenna did in his 1798 treatise on vaccination.
He declined the annihilation of the smallpox.
The most dreadful scourge of the human species must be the final results of this
practice. His words landed like a bomb. Napoleon calls vaccination.
The greatest gift of all time.
Thomas Jefferson told Jenna mankind's can never forget that you have lived by
1810, both Bavaria and Denmark had made vaccination mandatory in the following
decades. The vaccination slowly spread around the globe,
but Jenna's dream of a world without smallpox would never materialize.
Even as cases plunged the virus still stubbornly clung on still ruins
lives. Even as the 20th century reached its midpoint, but not for much.
By the beginning of the cold war.
I watch all of the West had already defeated smallpox.
The last U S case was in 1949, three years later,
North America was declared smallpox free a year after that Europe followed suit.
But even as parts of the world defeated the virus,
others were still left in its lethal grip. As late as 1967,
there were still some 10 to 15 million smallpox cases globally with parts of
Latin America, Africa and Asia hit badly.
But 1967 was also smallpox as last hurrah that same year,
the world health organization,
or who announced a plan to eradicate it completely.
It was an immediate unqualified success.
The speed at which smallpox was brought to heel seems dizzying today by 1971,
just four years after the program began,
it had been eradicated in Latin America.
This success was due to a new technique that emphasized contact tracing and mass
vaccination and new tank that included a freeze dried heat stable virus to use
in vaccinations in late 1975,
the final case was reported in Asia Rahima Banu was a three-year-old girl living
in Bangladesh. When she contracted Verrier to major, uh,
locally roles reported her to the who,
who responded with a massive lockdown Rahima Banu was isolated at home under 24
hour surveillance.
Every household within 2.5 kilometers was mass vaccinated and every public space
within eight kilometers was disinfected. It sounds like overkill,
but it worked went down. He recovered Verio to major was dead in the wind.
Two years later, very old minor struck for the last time.
And Merl Marlon was a hospital worker in Somalia tasked with looking after
Africa's lost smallpox patients on October the 22nd, 1977,
he himself came down with a disease and was quarantined.
He recovered that November and that was it for smallpox in Africa.
But the last day of a case of smallpox in human history,
it wouldn't happen and rural Bangladesh all out in Somalia.
It would happen in England. In the summer of 1978 hospital photographer,
Janet Parker began suffering a headache and bad muscle pain.
Shortly after red welts appeared across our body.
Stumped doctors tried all sorts of diagnoses.
It wasn't until she had been ill for two weeks that someone realized it was
smallpox by then. It was too late on September the 11th, 1978.
Janet Parker became the last person history to die from smallpox.
Although smallpox wouldn't kill anyone else in Birmingham,
the tragedy still claimed additional victims.
Design of Parker covered in pastels caused a father to have a fatal heart
attack.
When the source of the outbreak was traced to a lab in the university building
Parker worked and the head of the microbiology department slit his own throat.
Finally, on may the eighth, 1980,
the who declared the planet smallpox free after millennia of terror.
Humanity's worst plague had been defeated. Do they?
The disease exists only in two Catholic guarded labs,
one in Atlanta and one in Siberia.
Critics say these lost samples should be destroyed. Blessed.
They escape into the wild,
but supporters say the samples may one day become necessary.
Like if a new strain of pox similar to smallpox evolves naturally,
but rather than focusing on the negatives,
let's end this video on a high note for three decades,
smallpox stood alone as an anomaly.
The one disease in history would ever managed to eradicate.
Then in 2011, it was joined by another bovine.
Reinder past was called the measles of cattle killing in telling our herds until
we finally managed to stamp it out.
And we like to think of it as sort of a late, thank you. Present to cows,
the cow box and drawing the pest may not be the last currently Guinea worms,
the target of an intense eradication campaign. When the program started in 1986,
there were over 3.5 million cases a year in 2019,
there were fewer than 60.
The story of smallpox then is both a terrifying story of death and destruction,
but also one of hope for the first time ever in the face of a disease,
almost as old as civilization itself,
human Collins was able to come together and not just combat it,
but wipe his house barring an accident at one of those labs,
no one will ever again know the pain of losing someone to smallpox while
COVID-19 has showed us that disease is still something humanity has to fear.
The eradication of smallpox is evidence that we really can overcome it.
Given enough cooperation, given enough funding,
it really is possible to rid the world of a mobster smallpox.
His tail may have lost at millennia and cost millions of lives,
but it is now finally over the last chapter has ended and this time
happily that won't be a SQL. So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to support our sponsors who make these videos possible that today
would be dollar shave club, who I will link to below.
And thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].